let me first ask you about the news we
had out of Japan they've hit a recession
things in Europe also don't look so
great although car sales numbers weren't
terribly just pointing this morning but
in general it looks like those two
regions are hitting real rough spots and
not able to pull themselves out how does
that affect Bentley sales well we are
still doing pretty good as a matter of
fact we are heading for another record
year in 2014 so we have fairly stable
markets and the whole pack is led by the
US us is our biggest singing market
performance in the US market is very
good also we see good success in
continental Europe also our home country
in Great Britain is doing very well
things are a little bit slowing down in
China right now due to the political
situation and the bribery Act and with
the details that the investigations of
customers where do they get their money
from but it's still playing on a high
level China is the second biggest market
for US and Japan I think with the
recession that's going on in Japan that
will not influence the Bentley sales
because in the very upscale market in
the luxury performance segment people
always have enough money to purchase a
new car it's just a question of the
offer right the stock market is doing
quite well there it's just sort of the
middle class getting squeezed I guess is
the same story around the world so
luxury is your saving grace I suppose
except in the case of China what's
what's going on there with the bribery
scandal well in China customers get
investigated if they buy a very
luxurious product so the government is
checking where they got the money from
where I made it where they made it and
this slows down a little bit the market
but in total we will sell more cars this
year in China than we sold last year so
they also contribute to our record year
you have actually the most expensive
products I guess in the entire
Volkswagen Group at least under the
umbrella of Bugatti is there any need at
all to go down a little bit McLaren for
example is making some slightly more of
Florida
relative cars is that a possibility for
Bugatti for Bugatti we have the premium
position worldwide in the automotive
market these are the most exclusive
luxurious products you can afford and
there will be no drop down or and more
let's say affordable offer if you are
purchasing a Bugatti you made it to the
very top and there is no alternative
alright so what about Bentley I mean
there's so much talk about the SUV
coming out next year and for other car
companies that you've previously served
like Porsche it's been a massive massive
hit these big SUVs do you expect to
reach down a little bit in price well
interestingly at present the top line of
the SUV is limited around two hundred
thousand US dollars and if you have a
product with everything inside that's
what you can spend and there is nothing
above we are going to solve this problem
with the Bentley SUV we are doing
product that brings our perception of
the market the luxury and the
performance style to the SUV segment for
this reason we are in the middle of the
program right now the test cars are out
on the market we already get the first
reactions from customers that spotted
the car and we think that with an SUV we
can really enlarge in our customer group
about ninety-five percent of our
customers already have another SUV in
their garage so we know how old the car
is what it is and we think we can make a
good section in the market in the future
with an SUV offer all this talk about
super luxury makes me feel a little bit
silly asking the gasoline question but
I've got to ask all car makers is the
cheaper gas price having any effect on
your business does it matter to a
Bentley customer basically not but we
are influenced by the overall political
situation and our customers are
achievers in life they are business
people so they care about economic
factors and of course they know what's
the gas price what
what cost the electricity but basically
when they're on a gas station they
always fill it up I have of course there
and they will with this as well this
Gran convertible it's only a concept now
when can I go out and get my first
speeding ticket in this well we just
launched this concept here in Los
Angeles last night it's first off we are
keen to get the reactions from our
customers from the media about the
perception here in the US we think in
California we are right at the hot spot
of the market Pacific Highway the
lifestyle of the Californian car owners
the car of in others that are around
will give us some good feedback to this
car we hope it will be positive and if
we get the right feedback it takes us
about 12 months to bring it to life all
right well I love the shoulder lines
thanks so much explain some time with us
really appreciate it welcome to heimer
CEO president of Bentley Bugatti and in
charge of the motor sport unit so he is
a very busy man Betty